- [Presenter] This is
the Ukrainian village
of Nyzhni Sirohozy in the
occupied Kherson region
in October, 2022, and in March, 2023.
The new lines in the fields are rows
of Russian fortifications
built in anticipation
of a counter-offensive by Ukraine.
While Kyiv has been training its troops
to use Western weapons,
Russia has been building
some of the most extensive
defensive lines seen
anywhere in the world in decades,
according to Western intelligence.
(speaking in a foreign language)
A military analyst who spoke
to the "Wall Street Journal"
say they're skeptical of the effectiveness
of these defenses.
The "Journal" analyzed
satellite images and videos
from Russian media to understand
what Moscow's preparations
could mean for Ukraine.
Since the start of the invasion,
Russia has been digging
along the 900-mile front line
and even on its own territory.
Much of the work is focused
on the occupied areas
of the Zaporizhzhia and Kherson regions,
according to data collected
by a satellite image analyst.
British intelligence say
Russia has built 75 miles
of defensive lines in Zaporizhzhia.
This hints at where Russia expects
to be attacked by Ukraine,
and many Western analysts agree
that these territories
could be the main targets
of Ukraine's counteroffensive.
So here's what Russia has been building.
The first layer of defense
shown in many satellite images
is the anti-tank ditch.
The obstacle is meant to be
too wide for a tank to cross,
restricting an enemy's
ability to maneuver,
and funnel their forces into areas
that make them more vulnerable to attack.
Next are rows of concrete
blocks called dragon's teeth.
They form a barrier
that makes it difficult
for heavy vehicles to pass through.
And the third line is a trench.
This is the most common
type of defensive work
and the easiest to construct.
Russian forces dug many
trenches along roads,
junctions and bridges, and
even on the beaches of Crimea.
Most of them were built at
a zigzag or angular pattern.
This limit the sight lines for the enemy
and offers additional protection
from shell fragments coming from the side.
And Ukrainian forces are
likely to face further traps.
Military analysts believe landmines
have also been hidden
between defensive lines.
Ukraine's and Russia's ministries
of defense didn't respond
to our request for comments
on the significance
of Moscow's fortification efforts.
Some military experts
say these defense systems
don't necessarily pose a major
threat to the Ukrainians.
They say whether the
fortifications are effective
would depend on the number of
Russian troops defending them,
and if Ukraine attacks defensive lines
that aren't sufficiently protected,
the Ukrainians will be able
to bypass the obstacles
with Western Challenger
and Leopard battle tanks.
Experts say that in the end,
intelligence on the position
of Russian troops will be key
to Ukraine's counteroffensive,
and whether they can force
Russia to concentrate troops
in the wrong place and leave
defensive lines exposed.
(guns banging)